was willst du
servus leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem bändchen trouble in mein will muss
was lustiges los muss erstattet ja und
jetzt in der anfangs hektik ist jetzt
besser untergegangen was jetzt an werde
ich spiele heute mit zwei leuten diese
zwei leute sind denis hughes also denn
es ist leicht users ist leicht an der
box den kennt ihr ja schon aber ich habe
heute auch einen dabei die dir
garantiert noch nicht kennt und das ist
ja genau hallo
den hab ich auf entdeckt und der macht
gute videos deswegen hab ich das nämlich
im internet mit mein video und ja okay
ich hasse das die ganze diese immer das
ist so ein fail alter alter willst du
mich verarschen
ich habe gerade eben einen ersten
trailer gekillt okay okay okay ich komme
die mitte zum test erfolgt
wahrscheinlich werde ich nicht ich bin
am tester ich warte auf dich alter hatte
ich sag ich sag's euch einfach mal
ich wollte gerade sag ich euch also sage
ich nicht da würde ich sag's euch ich
wollte gerade meinen trade and trade up
as einsetzen und es hat einfach nicht
geklappt weil zu viele schnell eine
sache so eine scheiße alter das kann
nicht sein
dafür lassen hast du zwei
ja das war korrekt von ihm ok dann lasst
mal ein bisschen rumlaufen
ein bisschen theater so also ich denke
halt immer leute die nicht in der mitte
sind und keine detektive sind sind
wahrscheinlich trader so das ist aber
auch logisch
deswegen will ich die meistens ich
hinter mir ja was ist eigentlich mit dir
bist du alt bist du in oh ich bin okay
hier hinten ist eine seiner nichten oder
nicht ganz dahin gelegt es bekommt man
wenn man die kripo tötet frau die aber
der einreise liebe viele tote ja man ist
da aber die beiden sind da voll okay
okay das bringt nichts du bist einfach
läuft von direct ferner kann ich nichts
machen verraten
kommt jetzt der ein paar soll ich mein
geheimnisverrat ja man macht ich war
drei tage
du warst trägt vermutlich randy andy
carroll
so versammelten vertreter bist du da
jetzt aufgekommen
organist riskant vielleicht da
rausgekommen
nein ich habe jetzt wirklich nur
angestellter in der webcam fest
kambodscha leute 123 ist dabei und ja
ich weiß ja ich mein kopf das weiß
keiner
wir setzen kurzen cut schnipp schnapp
und leute da sind wir wieder
und ja ich hab einfach umgehauen
die filmklappe wieder so weck will noch
einmal eine komplette ps3 spiele hier
runter jetzt ist er als kate middleton
sekunden habt ihr noch alter
wer von euch nun schwert ich hab jetzt
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
oh mein gott oh mein gott walther
herzrasen herzrasen leute machen
ich liebe es einfach leuten frieden
anzuzeigen und sie dann kaputt zu hauen
ja ich habe einfach so ein zittern
gerade ist ganz allein 600 meter
hinunter
egal jetzt ins hauptgebäude und das
knapp über das knapp alter so hoch das
war jetzt nicht so gut gekämpft aber
egal ich deine geh halt dein maul ein
alter damit auf dem schießen schießen
immer auf ihn drauf rasch maras war okay
den stecken
er ist wieder dahin kommen wo wir schon
wieder getroffen den snack ich mir jetzt
hast du diese zwei shows gesehen alter
was für skills ihr alter noch ein
treffer weg
da kann man nichts machen als ok war ja
leute das war ja mal eine geile geile
aufnahme sich schon wieder ewig lang
scheiße war's
die kommt endlich ein bisschen später
und ja leute ich verabschiede mich jetzt
die der link von local es in der
beschreibung check in auf jeden fall mal
aus denn es könnte wahrscheinlich
schreien
trotzdem ist in der beschreibung also
check die beiden aus und wie immer gilt
es kay beantwortet alle kommentare also
schreibt fleißig in die kommentare
und da würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video hat einen schönen
tag und davos